[Music]
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody it is not frequent
that i get to talk to not only an
imminent cosmologist but someone who's
also a friend and a very deep and
critical thinker
and that is dr ann aegis who is joining
us all the way across the country i
believe anna where are you joining us
from today
right now from the new york area new
york where i got my personal big bang
began uh 50 years ago in new york uh
state and uh it's a delight to talk to
you thank you for uh agreeing to come on
the podcast
thanks for having me
you know i'm teaching cosmology this
quarter and uh it's an undergraduate
course and we always conclude with the
most interesting thing which is where
did the universe come from and
and the answer honest answer is we don't
really know but i want to ask you what
what is the most fascinating aspect of
why did you become a professional
cosmologist there's millions of things
you could do why did you become a
theoretical cosmologist
you know that's a great question because
um it i didn't exactly have a straight
path you know i didn't go to undergrad
and afterwards decided i would do phd in
physics and that will be cosmology it
really is that i did first a phd a quick
one and and and i was writing about the
philosophy of science
and uh then afterwards you know i was
done i was 25 and um people told why you
are so young
and you have a physics degree so why
don't you look if if you want to do
another phd in german it's quite common
that when there's two phds uh and and
why don't you look if you want to do it
in physics you had such good grades
you know
talk to some people and you know i was
talking to the person who was the second
reader of my thesis
back then in munich and he said well why
don't you look into cosmology because if
some big discovery will be happening
soon that probably will come from
cosmology
and you know i really cannot explain why
i took that you know at face value but i
just then started to take cosmology
courses uh um i enrolled as a phd
student
and um
i
you know
it was fascinating i was really lucky i
got my first cosmology course to i got
to hear it with doing it with lava
mokanov
the best person you can learn from
and um
i i just think i really liked it
and it's really a lot of questions
really intrigued me and
i really liked also the question that
you know as a cosmologist and i'm sure
this is something that you enjoy too you
really have to know a little about every
part of physics so so i think the
combination of um
first by somewhat of an accident coming
to the subject but also you know the
fact that um i would say i'm a
conceptual thinker i i like you know on
the one hand i like to go into the
smallest details of the activation and
the computer program on the other hand i
always like to keep the big picture and
cosmology is such a perfect subject for
uh uh for people who like both parts of
the story both the details and the big
picture and but but but you know really
the most fascinating part of this is
that we have so many open questions in
cosmology
yeah and then perhaps because we are
talking you're an experimentalist i
should also say um you know
what's more fascinating that we have
experimental access to all these
questions
so coming from the philosophy background
you would think all those questions
where is the universe come from where
are we going
what is our place in the universe those
are all more metaphysical questions and
then you realize no actually you guys
can go out and measure all the fear and
test all the theories that we make up so
so that that certainly adds to it why
it's so fascinating
yeah i agree with exactly your
perspective in fact when i teach my
students the first day of class i say
this is the only subject in the entire
physics department that covers every
subject in the physics department except
for one which is biophysics i have yet
to get into how biophysics works into
cosmo although i do talk about the
origin of life and things like that
maybe it could be someday i'll get some
you know i'll do a lab demo i started
doing lab demonstrations you know these
classes are so theoretical i use this
book by my friend barbara ryden which is
a wonderful book
uh and you know everybody in it and
everything in it is incredibly
theoretical except for you know we get
into derivations and so forth with the
einstein equations and gr and you and i
will talk a little bit about that
um so i just said i wonder if anyone's
ever did you know experiments uh you
know demonstrations in cosmology it
turns out there's a lot of things you
can do we have black body radiation we
have acoustic oscillations
tomorrow i'm going to be doing some
nuclear physics demonstrations i'm going
to be splitting the atom and i'm not
going to do that but they won't let me
do that with without some waivers but
they will uh hopefully i'll get some
heavy water some d2o and i'll bring in
some deuterium into the class and show
them how uh regular water ice cubes
float but deuterium ice cubes uh the
sink in ordinary water we'll see if that
actually works out if i have the budget
for it but it's fun to do experiments
and people love it and yet a lot of what
you know most people are interested in
when you talk to people like your
colleague you know brian greene or i've
had on neil degrasse tyson and i've had
on uh michio kaku and all sorts of great
names
you know people are really interested in
things like well can you tr you know can
a wormhole you know tell us about ads
cft and black hole information peridot
and some of these things are highly
philosophical and yet we never teach our
students about philosophy so i think you
came at it from a great perspective
starting with the philosophy moving in
theoretical domain and i wonder you know
from your perspective since you brought
it up
i tell my students that it's harder to
be an experimental cosmologist because
not only do you have to know everything
in your field of experiment but you have
to understand the theory
of what's behind it but i say you don't
have to do new theory in other words i
don't expect them to do the brilliant
things that that you and your colleagues
and your students work on but i do
expect them to be familiar with what
you're doing but not create it what do
you feel for an educated person as a
theorist what is the experiment is the
experimental minimum to use lenny
suskin's kind of terminology what would
you say for a theoretical cosmologist
what should he or she
know at a minimum about experiments in
general
well you know as much as one can i think
i think that there is you know
difficult to stay the minimum i never
thought about this i think you know
maybe if if we go concrete i think a
theoretical cosmology should definitely
be able to read a paper that is about uh
let's say cmb or dark energy any survey
data and not just to read it but also
understand the statistical methods can
read the you know the data the maps so i
don't think that you know it's important
um
not just to
let me say this way it's not enough to
know the six parameters i go to the
paper and look at the six cards logical
parameters they are fine but i have to
fit with my theory that's not the
minimum that's not even step minus one i
would say i think you know it's it's
really important to to be able to you
know converse with theorists and know of
the uh ongoing experiments i think it's
really uh sorry experimentalist i've
said this uh and and and you know what
what the most important experiments are
i also think it's very important you
know at least for me it's very important
you mentioned you know uh we actually
know each other to talk to
experimentalists so says it's important
for experimentalists to talk to
theorists i think it's really important
to know your experimentalists there are
different experimentalists go about the
experiments differently they have
different interests they have you know
different just as theories have
different strengths and weaknesses i
think it's really important for
for uh theorists to personally so beyond
being able to read the paper i think the
the minimum is also that you know at
least a bunch of leading
experimentalists personally so i would
add that definitely you know your
experimentalists know whom you can ask
about something if you are not quite
sure uh follow every release uh you know
be up to date and and don't say oh i'm a
theorist i don't have to know everything
nobody eject knife test is if you wish
uh you know uh know when when you guys
go to atacama about everything it takes
and and i have respect for what
experimentalists are doing i mean i
haven't
you know an immense respect for you guys
what you are doing uh it's just it's
just really amazing you know just the
fact that you know i suffer from autism
sickness just the fact that you climb up
those mountains and spend a lot of time
to build those telescopes uh uh you know
just this minor aspect that's for you
probably second nature you know i think
it's really important that apart from
you know that here at also the
theoretical minimum experiments you have
personal relationship and personal
appreciation and and understand that
it's really important to talk to one
another you know learn the language
learn the language what experimentalists
will understand and experimentally
should understand the theories so i
think it's just like you know be friends
be good friends
because i think is the minimum yeah and
have an open open mind open attitude
that you know it's that it takes both of
us to do what we do
and i think you know what's what's
interesting to me is that yeah we come
to the conclusion that kids take this
class presumably because they're
interested in the beginning of the
universe and on the first day they're
disappointed because i say we don't
really discuss the beginning of the
universe because first of all we don't
know if there was a beginning a single
beginning b we don't know much about its
visibility and viability but also
because the subject that we study just
like biology you don't start with the
origin of life when you take a biology
class either you start dissecting frogs
or you know i don't know what they do in
biology but uh
i think the dean needs to check them out
uh but uh but in reality we don't really
start with cosmogeny so uh most people i
don't teach cyclic cosmology in my
cosmology class as interested as i am in
it um so to what extent do people object
to the study of the cyclic universe what
is the kind of uh objection that people
most present about the cyclic universe i
do
you know i think we have to start
probably historically what used to be
the objections and and very often people
come back with those objections uh also
just to know if one already has an
answer for them
so
as you mentioned probably if one took a
survey among all people in the world we
would find more people who for one
reason or the other whether it's
religious whether it's you know due to
their upbringing uh we would find more
who who have some cyclic worldview so
that's that's uh i think comes very
natural to people in certain parts of
the world and people who grew up perhaps
in a more western culture uh
um more linearly think that you know
there has to be actually everything a
beginning and an end and in between some
trajectory very causal uh uh uh linearly
directed thinking
um and so everything comes from i think
you feel a little uncomfortable so i
think the first feeling is you know this
is not what i learned when i was a child
that i went to school i always thought
the universe had to have a beginning
that was some sort of an explosion and
that explosion gave rise to everything
and now you come to me and say that that
the big bang even if it happened wasn't
an explosion but maybe it didn't happen
maybe it was just a transition from from
a contracting preface and i think that
the first i think one really has to take
it seriously and this is always the case
right when they teach people something
something in physic that's against our
everyday intuition it it doesn't really
matter whether it's energy conversion or
whether it's you know uh gravity or
quantum field theory it's always the
fact that people are uncomfortable with
the idea that what the idea that they
grew up with it might not be the idea or
might not be how nature works so i think
that you know that is the basic uh um
attitude right now in certain parts of
the world and uh uh most physicists grew
up with this idea so i think that that
is really something that i i take very
seriously that uh you know people come
with some preconceptions and they like
those preconceptions and then comes the
physics right so when we um um
the first time realized that einstein's
theory of general relativity describes
the evolution of the universe on large
scales then um we i should say alexander
friedman also realized that that the
universe could choose three uh different
ways to evolve and one of so it could
expand
it could contract or it could oscillate
between and he caught an oscillating
model between contraction to expansion
contraction to expansion and that was
you know he called it oscillating
universe but
um this is i would say the first modern
uh um version of a cyclic universe now
there were some issues with with
friedman's model and that was very
quickly pointed out by tormund so
tormund was was was the person that is
being most often quoted when it comes to
what's wrong with the psychic why might
the cyclic universe be a wrong idea
and um
we will probably get back to this but
tormund is very simply very often quoted
in the way oh orality tormund has shown
that somehow uh um a cyclic universe
violates the second law of
thermodynamics so i think that's what
some people call it the entropy problem
so this is the thing
the critique that most people would
bring up not necessarily um
because they believe in it or they read
tormund but you have heard it one way or
the other that that probably a cyclic
universe has some sort of entropy
problem so that's because you're
collapsing
because in his model
yeah so so so there are three aspects of
this problem and you know you tell me uh
as to what degree you want to dive into
this but tormund had uh this aspect has
three problems or the problem has three
aspects
uh the one the one is i turned around
the sentence the the first one is you
know that in um
as friedman imagined it and that was the
model that that that thomann criticized
every single cycle is the same so the
universe contracts um then balances then
expands contracts then bounces and
expands and the contraction happens in a
way that all physical distances
eventually and we know it doesn't make
much sense since we since then uh that
is just from the quantum
perspective not make sense uh collapse a
single point
right that is that is and that that uh
that everything crunches into
into a point or a point like something
so all black holes in the universe
collapsed
together and there is some big mass
created so that was one of the aspects
of the problem there are two more
aspects of the problem uh the second one
is is really the question if everything
you know crunches uh don't you uh um
is that do you need to infinite entropy
stage try can you get out of that phase
and there was a third aspect to the
problem and this is a more modern aspect
to the problem that was people were uh
and and i uh have taught a lot about
that aspect namely higher space time so
people believe for a very long time up
until i would say a few years ago that
contracting universes uh
to einstein behave in a very specific
way and now we have to dive in a little
bit and because because if you ask me
what would be the most serious problem
it will turn out that the problem that
people talk least about is physically
the most serious problem that you have
to overcome and this has something to do
with the fact again we go back to where
does our intuition come from from
contraction and how does einstein
relativity tells us all of our
institution actually javi imagine it is
wrong it's newtonian
and it it is really the
idea if i tell you
you have to imagine some contracting
space or space time
what you will
think of is inhomogeneity is growing
everything is collapsing eventually
probably
a mass is being created or you end up
with a big black hole right that's what
that's what most of us first thing of a
contraction gravitational collapse is
contraction so a contracting universe is
perhaps like a big black hole is a black
hole in the making and that's not
exactly a good condition for
transiting transitioning to a universe
that is simple flat smooth as beautiful
as you can imagine from both from the
distribution of the geometry and then
from another perspective
and i promise you know our intuition is
never never really right within einstein
gravity now it turns out really if you
look at contracting universes
um
contraction is anything but collapse so
instead of the gradients growing
einstein theory tells you and it has
been has been a long time conjecture and
mathematicians have been lately proving
theorems about it and i have been uh
doing simulations for numerical
relativity simulations just the same
methods you know as people used to to
simulate colliding black holes to check
this pers this conjecture which says
contraction is not collapse instead of
your gradient your inhomogeneity is your
mass growing space-time as it contracts
it it actually inhomogeneous vanish and
um
it you become
instead of inhomogeneous in homogeneous
you become an isotropic so only thing
what matters is all gradients all
connectedness within space-time vanishes
so instead of a collapse what happens is
space-time point starts to develop
independently of one another
and so contraction is not collapsed but
is it good enough is it a homogeneous
but an isotropic universe good enough
for a bounce well no
you know if if if if uh uh
you might want to show another one of
the simulations as i send you uh uh and
and i can i can show that to you so we
we know how contracting universe we can
check it and it's really true that the
gradients vanish but what happens is
something that's one cause a mix master
chaos or mess so because the space time
points develop independently of one
another what really happens is that that
in each point
if you were sitting in one point what
you would observe is that in one
direction space-time contracts into
other direction it expands and at
different rates
and this is not great because what
happens is really that that that's why
people call it cases it's so chaotic
behavior of the geometry itself
and um and this is a third aspect of
what we can call under the torment
problem that a contracting universe one
way or the other is not a good
precondition for a bands for
transitioning to an expanding universe
so that's i think you know if you are a
really sophisticated reader of the
literature this would be the three
critique points that you would quote uh
what could be the problem uh with the
contract think universe is the it's the
crunch problem it's the entropy problem
or contradiction with the second law and
it is the mixed master chaos problem the
space-time geometries become really
crazy even though you don't collapse you
become chaotic and very anisotropic
so it's a long answer for a short
question
right so do you think it's uh you know
sometimes i feel like a lot of these
things are problems of marketing like
and because we're so used to teaching
the story of the friedman equations and
and it's so rich to teach the uh
relativistic equations which can involve
things like the spatial curvature of the
universe but you and i just finished
singing the praises of my
experimentalist friends ranging from
you know lyman page and the toco
experiment back in 1998
and then the boomerang and maxima
experiments in 99 2000
we known for 22 years now that the
universe has zero spatial spatial
curvature and yet i spend a week
teaching my students out of the ten
weeks i have about this so uh is that
because you know the math is so elegant
and and so beautiful even though i mean
we don't teach about well there used to
be that there you know the universe
could have essentially you know begun
from a uh you know from a static or
quasi-static state and actually we don't
know how uh is it a problem of of
advertising or marketing or is there
some some other reason why you think
that people
aren't as familiar with cyclic universes
in the context of of the history of
cosmology but even current uh uh current
work and investigations do you feel like
there's a basically a marketing problem
so to
speak um
that's a tough question
you know i i actually think um
you can call it a marketing problem
but i believe that you know very often
we teach um
different subjects in physics as people
um as ideas developed how they came to
know about them for example and i don't
so
when you mention spatial curvature so a
lot and and we should also praise the
theorist of the last uh 40 or 50 years
um how he came to our current model
harvey just came to appreciate that we
might need something to patch the old
hot big bang model that you know really
describes our universe we call it hot
big bang but it's really the description
between let's say nuclear synthesis and
today um that that that people realize
well um first you know they looked out
to the universe um those were you know
your previous colleagues starting with
friedman so this is this is this is the
universe is expanding
and it's geometry you already named the
friedman equations is very elegant
it doesn't matter where you are in what
direction you look that's what we call
homogeneous and isotropic uh it's
everywhere the same on large scales of
course not on small scales this is crazy
well everything looks different when we
look around but we if we go to large
enough scales beyond the scale of
galaxies then everything looks very
elegant
and you would think that simplicity is
maybe this is very natural right so that
that's what we're doing how could it be
different why would it not be simple why
would it not be the simplest possibility
and
i think you know in science it's really
important to be unconventional very
often when you want to find something
new and people say well let's check it
and let's check it again einstein
relativity what does relativity tells us
what if we let's just run the movie
backwards starting from today would it
be let's just with the simplest
deviation and the simplest deviation is
your curvature term let's see if that
curvature can remain small if we started
start with it being small today
and a lot of people discovered it's
actually growing right
so but but what really happened is that
there is an instability even if you
start with small but not exceedingly
small curvature you would have to see
today given the acquisitions with which
that you use to describe the large-scale
evolution but you would have to seize
large curvature contributions and that's
how you know that was really i think a
very very short history to the to the uh
to the you know upcoming of this
discomfort that maybe the the hot big
bang theory is incomplete and that's why
i think you know one teaches it this way
now um
and that was also very important insight
that led them to to the development of
inflationary cosmology out of which i
should say than then then the cyclic
considerations go out
some people who developed inflationary
cosmology those are the same people who
who the first contributors the cyclic
cosmology and then i think you know it
is really just it stuck it stuck this
explanation that you know we just look
at the friedman equation with some
curvature because it has been so helpful
in the past
but you know what many people don't
teach you know and i i find you know
looking at just the contracting solution
of the friedman equation so educational
because it tells you so much about you
just learn so much about how gravity
behaves in the context of einstein
relativity that we believe is a
description of of of of gravity uh on
many many scales is the correct
description and so if you you know i
think that both the relativists and the
cosmologists just teach it for the first
uh you know the first reason should be
you learn so much
first of all most people don't know that
the friedman equations right they admit
both a contracting or an expanding
solution
and it's in the initial conditions we
tell the equations whether we want to
have the contracting or expanding
solution why don't we not teach it i
think it's historical and then now you
tell me um
should one teach you absolutely
absolutely one should teach it both to
get the right intuition about gravity
but then afterwards you know what and
that's what i got so excited about is
you know it really opens up a completely
new set of possibilities that might be
actually the right explanation of what
we see when we look out for example into
the microwave background
so i would agree with you again yeah it
has a marketing problem yeah
yeah i think so too and actually you
know when i think about even the
explanation that inflation purports to
provide i think where inflation has been
successful is not in explaining where
the universe came from or explaining
where the elements came from or all
sorts of things because oftentimes it
raises more questions than it actually
answers but rather as a theory of
structure formation and before we get to
how structures can
can occur in a cyclic and the new cyclic
cosmology that you and others have
developed
i wonder if we could you know kind of
explain this most common objection that
i spoke about with will kinney a few
months back for his book an infinity of
worlds which involves you know doesn't
shy away from you know the kind of
quantum runaway as you guys call it the
uh the multiverse problem in fact it
embraces it as a core tenant of of his
work which i endorsed on the back of his
book along with your friend the other
more popular brian of cosmology there in
new york city area um but i want to ask
you uh what what he seemed to say was a
objection to the uh to the bouncing
model was this this issue of geodesic
completion i wonder what what does that
mean and why doesn't it afflict uh the
the bouncing model just the same way uh
or the inflationary model perhaps um is
it uh maybe worth detouring first to
talk about the border guthvalankin
theorem and can you talk about what is
what is a geodesic and what does
geodesically complete mean and then
maybe we'll get into this bgv uh ideas
maybe but you know um
it's actually a really technical concept
right so i'm very happy to talk about it
because yeah my audience is yeah
universe or multiverse according to
that's great to hear
uh no i actually just attended a
conference last week and i was chatting
with roger penrose about judaism
completeness in cyclic cosmologies so um
we share a lot of you know um intuition
ideas how it might work but let's get
back to i mentioned raja for a
particular reason because one has to
start really with him and and and
stephen hawking them and start to talk
about geodesic completeness since uh
comp judaism completeness is really a
technical feature of um einstein gravity
and this came up um
in their
first and probably up until today most
prominently more prominently probably
than the bgv or board goodwillenkin
theorems the uh hawking penrose
singularity theorems they actually
should be called incompleteness theorems
because what they show is
that in a certain sense so if you follow
the geodesics uh is uh the path that's
within relativity massive particles
travel
and um
the question was you know how far back
in time can you follow the path of
massive particles uh finitely or
infinitely far
and uh um
but panders and hawking have shown very
simply speaking so none of my
mathematician's friend would you know
probably approve this at a higher level
but if you want to have the shortest
explanation and they say what they have
shown is that
general relativity is incomplete
geodesically incomplete because within
finite time massive particles uh uh
reach a singular singular surface your
audience is brilliant so i can call it
this way sorry to singularity and that's
how the singularity theorems talk but
it's really a geodesic incompleteness
theorem about about relativity and what
about penrose and hawking have been uh
um interested in or very interested in
was were expanding
space time that expand at a decelerated
rate let's say simply matter or
radiation dominated space time that
those space times were also uh that
describing the whole big bang model
there was this time that start with
maybe radiation domination and another
domination it would apply also to space
times that are mad or dominant or
universes and are described by einstein
gravity
and neither what but and it's very
simple now that you you have this
concept of what they were following they
were following the trajectories of
massive particles
uh what
board good and vlan can add it to is
they extended the theorem to
space time that involve an inflationary
pace that involve acceleration and they
have shown that space-time that are
expanding at an accelerated rate
inflationary space-time for example are
also geodesically incomplete so if you
follow the
a path of massive particles now what you
will see is within a uh um
finite time
uh
in certain coordinates um they call it
conformal coordinates but this is really
technical so that the important thing
was that you reach a singular surface
that was that was important about uh
board goodwill now
why is it important why would one care
about technical terms in cosmology but
some people actually use this to show
that the universe necessarily need to
have a beginning right
and um uh i think that that's when when
one goes beyond what the mathematics
tells you what the theory tells you it's
really a feature of a theory you cannot
tell if you just use einstein gravity
then the acquisitions break down after
at a certain point it's more like a
noble theorem which is one of my
problems with a lot of inflation you
know with the slow roll conditions i
often hear and i can say this because
i'm not working in this field even if
you don't uh you know subscribe to what
i'm saying but people say oh the the
slow roll inflation ends when the slow
roll conditions end you know when
they're violated but i'm like well wait
how does how does the infilton know
anything about what we call the slow
roll it just seems like that's a that's
a consistency problem for us to deal
with but you know it's like if they say
about birds you know birds don't really
need the study of ornithologists to you
know to know how they go about their
daily business so isn't this just saying
that that the univ that the math breaks
down at a certain point and what we have
now needs a quantum theory of gravity
not that there's a big bang or a
singularity isn't that sorry
i think this is a perfect interpretation
of it by the way pandoras who introduce
the singularity theorems works on cyclic
cosmologists right i mean i know that
roger is your good friend so so
many people because i should have
started maybe i should not put thoma
maybe nowadays of course many people say
but don't the singularity theorems prove
the big bang no they prove really as you
said it i don't think that one can say
it better than you said it brian that uh
space time no no
no honestly uh high praise from you
but if it's true one has to say it um so
um the the einstein equations are not
you know um very suited to explain the
but whatever is what what you call
either a big bang or a bounce or
whatever or in rogers model a transition
from one as he called it eon to another
this is this is exactly what it is but
you know i should not i don't think that
it's good to um in a certain sense i was
oh is it important i also think that
it's important because whenever we see
whenever we can point out the limitation
of a theory that opens up on your
question we know oh okay this is really
important the singularity theorems or
boot board goods villain can uh um are
important because we know that those
space if you want to explain where do
space time come from as and you know as
theories but also then later as
experimentalists you should be
interested in explaining and then
showing it then we have to know what the
limit limitations of our theories are
and in that sense it's helpful but of
course that's what i'm saying perfect uh
formulation um
it doesn't tell anything about what
replaces the einstein equations there
and what physics that replacement
know about the theorems so it's
mathematics uh so they they the theorem
rests on certain assumptions and one
assumption is of course that gravity is
described by einstein relativity but
there is a more important assumption
these theorems rest on the assumption
that the masses of particles remain
constant
and that's a very strong assumption and
under that assumption
and it was already shown if you read the
i think second to last uh or something
like the the last column in the printed
version of word good willing paper they
show that under that assumption
you can have a cyclic universe that
includes infinitely many cycles and is
nevertheless geologically incomplete and
this is true this is definitely where
where the where the state where the
field was uh about 20 years ago so
whatever cyclic model i would take
whether this is the model that i work on
whether it's the model that that
colleagues worked on uh um um let's say
whether it's stein turok whether it's
brandenburger whoever
works on these models as long as you
keep the the mass of uh of of your
particles constant the theorems apply
and as long as your theory of gravity is
einstein gravity or certain energy
condition as we call it which is a
somewhat of an equivalent statement are
satisfied now there was a brilliant uh
um
recognition and and i think it came from
really two directions one of them is
roger and the other one were
uh
it tag bars who is actually very close
to you sitting at the university of
southern california uh neil turok and
paul steinhardt in about a little bit
over 10 years ago they say well uh
they know from fundamental physics
whether you think of the higgs or
whether you think of some sort of
symmetry restoration in the early
universe that is probably not true that
the masses of particles remain constant
whether due to the higgs mechanism that
you know for example and that was the
bar steinhardt turok idea the multi
particles gain a very big mass during
contraction or the pendulum is a
beautiful product idea that maybe due to
the restoration of conformal symmetry
around the transition from from one
cycle to the other the particles become
massless so in two ways
you can break the assumptions of the
theorem and you know really this is
unfortunate not my idea i was a grad
student back then i wrote to you earlier
and i was really envious of this idea
because then you can compute can this is
physicists talk about it and i'm sure
your audience knows it uh since you have
had a lot of uh more technical
discussions with guests than with me and
that one one formulates this question uh
of how far can i drag back uh uh uh the
word line of massive particles as a in a
form of an integral and if one has a
varying mass whether due to the higgs
mechanism you make them big and heavy
during the contracting phase or you make
the massless during during uh
a conformer uh
symmetry restoration or due to conformal
symmetry restoration it turns out that
those integrals uh um don't converge as
we say they are not finite so they you
evade the the
the conclusions of of the word
singularity theorems or incompleteness
theorems so so it's you know it's fairly
uh well cited in the literature of these
papers especially the the the bars uh
steinhardt rock papers so um
i would say that this is very elegant
so that that's what shows that you know
you can have cyclic universes that are
geodesically
complete now i must say that you know i
don't know if you couldn't apply this to
just an eternally expanding universe uh
um
one should look at it i think it's an
open question but it's a really
important insight and i would want to
emphasize it
that
the assumptions of the theorems
are really important and loopholes are
of course always in which which of the
assumptions are related to which of the
assumptions
might be relaxed might be meaningfully
relaxed uh for the physical world and
this is here the constant mass of the
particles but i should say really i'm
really really sad that this wasn't my
idea this is something that you know i
would have loved the figures
yeah including uh you know one of the
ones that i associate with you maybe
maybe uh you know it's just i'll i can i
can just give you so much praise but you
know this issue that really appeals to
me so much is
you know something you pointed out to me
a long time ago or a couple of years now
which you know before covet and
everything seems like decades ago
and that was this idea that the key kind
of core idea is that the contraction is
slow
and we have this in your model and we
have this notion you know the big the
big crunch is like the inverse of the
big bang and therefore it's going to be
this violent you know disruptive
incredibly you know monumental uh
occurrence but if you you convince me
um
you know that this is not the case so
maybe you can speak about these ideas
that that you you've worked so so
assiduously on what what is the idea of
slow of slow contraction how does that
play in and really solve all these
problems that plague uh previous
attempts going back 100 years almost
i think there are you know it's
important to um um
look at both aspects of the cyclic
evolution but there are really three but
the third one we all know end on
question that's the current expanding
phase right um so so cyclic
cyclocosmologists have really have to
tackle three parts the one is we will
talk about it in a second the slow
contraction phase that's the phase that
precedes the bounds
and uh in
models of cyclic cosmology it's really
important this is the phase during which
the conditions are being generated that
should explain the large-scale structure
that we observe today that you guys
observe when you look into your
telescopes
um the contracting phase uh is connected
to the hot expanding phase
biocosmological bands
and typically you know cosmology and
cosmologists since you know
since really since they uh um um into
introduction of inflation work in a a
modular way so cosmologists are very
modular so you often focus on one phase
try to tackle the problems and then you
hope then you can attach them onto to
the next phase and then you hope that
you can attach them to the next phase
and in this sense you know what what i i
believe we all agree on really because
you know
you and your colleagues have shown it so
so uh beautifully and convincingly is
the hot expanding phase so between
nuclear synthesis and today when we are
just entering dark energy domination
that you know there is very little room
to figure
one can work on what the dark matter is
but that you know uh the large-scale
evolution is very well described by if
we just as you measure it we know that
what uh um
about what percentage of the total
energy densities matter that's enough
for us and it's very important question
what the dark matter is but but but you
know that it's not so important from the
from the perspective of can i describe
the large-scale evolution and now when
we come to the contracting phase so
let's let's put
let's think in a modular way so put the
bounds aside a little bit and let's
let's let's talk about the contracting
phase because that's really something
um
as this that is something that we can
that describe
uh simulate
and uh make predictions um about or
using it by way of it and the
contracting phrases you know for just to
understand what's happening
it's really important that we often
speak about contraction expansion
accident expansion decelerated expansion
slow contraction fast contraction what's
really important you know to to
invoke is that
within relativity you always have to
think of two scales
you cannot just talk about you know what
to
object in space time for example two
black holes do relative to one another
that's you know if they move apart from
one another that's expansion if they are
if the distance between them is
shrinking that's what they call
contraction but for cosmologists it's
very important
um to look at the second quantity and
this is the quantity uh uh that tells us
as to how far we can see at a given time
this is a hubble radius right so we have
we have we have or or we can say it
roughly this is the distance of causal
interactions and for cosmology is really
important and this is something we
learned
from people who first developed
inflation how important it is to to
solve cosmological problems
to look at booth scales at the same time
and the relative uh
dynamics of the two scales and it's
important as the beauty of einstein
relativity that the
distance between between objects or
physical distances move at a different
rate evolve at a different rate
than than than the hubble radius so the
the scale of interactions of causal
interactions and what the rate is it is
it is determined by the matter content
of the universe so what is slow
contraction but let's start with what is
a decelerated expansion if if the
universe is dominated by radiation or
matter
then what we know is then the hover
radius is expanding faster than the
distances between objects and that's the
reason why we see more than what was in
our causal past and that's that's that's
one way of saying that we have an
initial conditions problem today we know
we see actually 10 to the 28 10 to the
29 hubble patches that's where hubble
patches in the early universe that is
one way of saying we have a problem
because they should not have interacted
with one another now slow contract is
decelerating because because physical
distances
expand slower and it will be important
for slow contraction relative to the
hover radius now if you want to solve
this problem what we learned since the
80s what you have to do is that physical
distances again move at a different rate
but in in a certain sense in an inverse
wave what do we need we need that that
when we start and that was the original
idea of inflation too when we started
one hubble patch that has almost the
right features we want to extend the
features of the trouble patch over many
many hubble patches by the by the end of
this phase and what does slow
contraction do you start with a huge
hubble patch low at very low energies
and what you say is we will hardly move
physical distances uh towards one
another that's why it's slow but what
moves fastest on the other hand uh you
shrink on on on on your physical patch
um
the hubble radius at a very fast rate so
slow contraction is slow if you're a
black hole or a local app server but
it's very fast from from the perspective
of the hubble pace so all of a sudden
you lose sight very quickly you lose
sight of many things why is this good
well it is good because uh um
by this this this this um dynamics is
occurring two very important things
happen which we know and you know since
uh um uh you are a cosmologist they are
both important the first thing is
obviously they extend local features on
super hubble scales that's really
important because we see today that the
same features extend over exponentially
many hobble skills so that's given to
you and and that's a really elegant it
comes out automatically of the theory
this slow contraction means you cannot
help it features become uh extended over
super hubble scales but it's a second
more important thing and this is
something i've worked on a lot lately
it turns out you can write it down
pencil and paper it's much nicer to do
it with the computer so so you can start
with you know any kind of initial
conditions and what i mean is metric
configuration you have come very messy
geometry you can have lots of curvature
uh lots of anisotropis the sheer uh
directionality in in your geometry your
your uh matter content can be very messy
the only important thing is you have
particular scalar failure in that if you
have a particular scalar field and it
doesn't have to dominate the energy
density it doesn't have to have an
elegant distribution the only thing what
you need for it is that it has a uh
potential energy uh which is negative
sufficient to negative and the potential
energy curve is sufficiently steep then
you can start with almost arbitrary
initial conditions and this will give
you um a flat and smooth universe so
this is beautiful and why it's happening
well it's happening for two reasons
the one reason is um this it looks so
space time and this is something i want
to get
back to a point that people told you
remember i said the concern with
contracting universe was not that it's
collapsing with an einstein gravity but
it's becoming an isotropic dominated so
everybody is sheer and that's not i mean
you know it's not how the microwave
background looks it's not how a large
scale universe looked but what happens
really is if you have the differences
the difference between those
considerations and our consideration is
the scalar
once you drop into the scalar field that
could be the higgs you know it could be
that the hicks has a true negative
minimum or some other scalar and and
once once you have the scalar it turns
out that that space time becomes still
local the gradients finish so for free
as in every contracting space time you
don't have to be worried about
inhomogeneities half of our price is
done it it it out of the task is done
and the second thing what happens is
instead of going to a mess this scalar
with a negative potential energy density
test space time
i'm talking here metaphorically but it's
really the case what you see that makes
all the difference since instead of
going to this chaotic uh uh um uh um
mess which is a shear dominated you go
to a flat friedman robertson walker so
that's the beauty of it and this is now
support that that the
smoothness and flatness is on super
hubble scales and that it's generated
from starting from really really orbit
nearly arbitrary initial conditions you
know this is something that makes it
very exciting um
to look at these cosmologists
also because you didn't introduce any
different theory of gravity
so so everything what you need to
explain flatness and smoothness is given
to you with einstein gravity
contracting universe if there is a
scalar field that has a sufficiently
steep negative potential
to next because you and i
because you and i had a friendly debate
and again you know i'm so grateful to
have friends like you that can explain
things to me that i'm a simple
experimentalist but i have a great uh
detail of detailed affection for ideas
both classical and and new ideas like
you have
brought so many creative new ideas to
this field um but you know i always uh
say that it would be great you know if
there was an alternative to inflation
that didn't have a scalar field because
the thing that most troubles me until
you know 2012 we didn't know of any
scalar fields that existed let alone one
that was cosmologically important and
then of course we we suspected the higgs
existed but the higgs is the only known
scalar field and so i thought well you
know it would be great if instead of the
infliton you shouldn't multiply
hypotheses as i think uh descartes said
or somebody said way back when and you
should never uh have excessive uh
excessive
you know parameters if you will in
modern parlance
and and you corrected me because you
said well you know what is what's so bad
about a scalar field you didn't fight
back you know the way that say sir roger
does right sir roger has these error
bonds and and again he's a friend of
mine
and so uh and i push back on him too
because i say you know he has these he
doesn't have a scalar field per se but
then he has to account for how dark
matter evolves because the dark matter
is providing
some you know version of this effect
that that you are solving with the
scalar field so um now you corrected me
and i wonder if you can if you can
recapitulate that uh why is it not so
uh so troublesome to have a scalar field
in the bouncing alternative models to
inflation
well i think you know in general
what i wrote to you is it's in general
not troublesome to have a scalar field
in my point of view you know um
it's probably one has to pan back a
little bit because um
a lot of things higher judge your theory
depends on what you expect from a theory
what you think a theory should deliver
and under what condition what you accept
as an uh as a good ingredient or as an
acceptable ingredient and what you don't
and um i believe
you know the the the simple explanation
is we haven't found anything simpler
that delivers us uh the same so i think
that you know the the idea of simplicity
um with respect to theories is it's a
little bit of a um
it can be used in very different ways
but
it's always a relative um
a concept right you have two theories
and if they make if they give you the
same amount if they deliver the same
amount then you can say the simpler
theory
should be preferred
and what do i mean here well first of
all we need the background flatness and
smoothness but we also need the origin
of structure so we also need
the the the source of of of um what
reveals that structure which reveals
itself as as temperature and isotropic
of the microwave background so if we
need that then we know that those are
sourced by some scalar degree of freedom
now
um it might be a condensate there would
not be a scalar field but right now our
best descriptions are
using the scalar and the second reason
why i find you know uh the scale isn't
that you know you know it because we
have corresponded about that that um
we know
how to introduce quantum fluctuations
for a scalar field on a locally flat
background we know we know quantum field
theorem and flat background and our best
knowledge tells us and our best
observations of the microwave background
that the origin of the temperature and
isotropics are quantum fluctuations uh
in
the curvature
which is a scalar degree of freedom but
we believe that was excited by some
scalar
strep matter density which is a scalar
field so this is a complicated
explanation but the point is scalar
fluctuations
in a scalar field will lead to scale of
fluctuations in the curvature which
relate to temperature fluctuation the
microwave background so you need some
sort of scalar that was my answer
and because we excite the scalar degree
of freedom of the metric therefore it
doesn't seem to be so unnatural to have
a scalar field that does it now you
could say well this is circular right
you know what you have to do therefore
you introduce a skill of it how do you
know a condensate couldn't do it how do
you let something ask you don't do it
but i don't and you know i think that
it's important that people look into
alternatives
i can live with it because overall in
theoretical physics but just because i
can live with it and i think you know
for me it's more important right now to
figure out if i can you know uh generate
a good uh advanced model can put it on
the computer and therefore i won't look
at uh right now look into it if i can
have a better idea i think it's very
important to explore so therefore you
know um just because i can live with it
that doesn't mean that this is the
simplest explanation possible i think
it's simple enough
um for the purposes that we need it for
but if we had a simpler explanation but
we need another ingredient you know
because i appreciate that you
experimentalists would like to measure
directly whatever generates the
microwave background and this invisible
field whether it's during inflation or
during slow contraction is a little bit
bothersome right so i appreciated that
you know this is this is something that
you know um you would like to exchange
or trade for something that can be
directly measured so i think people
should go for it and see if one can
replace it by something simpler but
right now for the reasons it's a little
bit of a theoretical reasons i'm not
bothered by
and because it's you know overall in
theoretical physics
let me ask if the uh the final remaining
minutes before i jump on uh not a
telescope anna unfortunately i spend
most of my time on telecons but uh and i
i do conversations like these because it
makes me sane and i appreciate i want to
get because i can't resist um
what is your take on the hubble tension
is there is is there something
fundamental at work here
is it more prosaic that you know we
missed the systematic or uh and so for
i'll be talking with adam reese uh this
week by the time my interview with you
airs this interview uh it'll be long in
the past so do tune in uh in the in the
past i don't know that violates
causality uh but anyway anna um so he's
gonna be talking obviously he has new
measurement kind of uh percent level uh
measurement of the hubble uh constant do
you think there's anything else that
could be going on or let me ask you is
there do you have a an explanation
you know that you prefer hypothetically
for
resolving this is it is it a fundamental
issue that could be shaking things up or
is it more likely to be a systematic
error as i think
you say um i i was telling you know i
think it's important if you're a
theorist to have good friends
um and among experimentalists and you
know whom you trust and maybe did a
pre-selection or not or whom you does
more of course you trust everyone by
them you trust more and i would say
those people that i trust most tell me
that um
it's it's likely not physics it's likely
systematics i'm not i'm not an analyst
and i'm not a not an observer so i would
say the people
uh who might trust would not yet
be ready to declare it that is that is a
mild expression some are very um sure
it's it's uh systematic so
um you know i think it relates a little
bit high view this um have you
everything um
whether it was you know bicep two
whether it's this dungeon or the
uh um
an isotopic spot i like to wait wait it
out you know i um i don't like um
ambulance chasing so i'm not the type of
physicist that that you know writes down
a model for every anomaly that one can
have i think it's important actually
probably it sounds a little dismissive
but i don't mean it that way i think
it's really important to have to have
people in the field who are very
creative quick creative and whenever
something comes up they tell you well
that's what you would need to do in
order to accommodate that but then the
second step is also important if it's
complicated and i would call early dark
energy complicated um
then probably the last one is maybe that
hints us you know either
you have to work harder to have a better
explanation or it's really systematic
but i like to you know i i actually more
of there is i like to wait i like to
let
experimentalists and analysts work it
out first and then when it's really
profoundly established you know uh um at
the five plus sigma level that's when i
would turn to it so i like to follow
these debates but it's more you know
it's really my approach to to to these
things i don't think that everybody
should have the same approach but you
know i have my own approach i'm more uh
you know working on fundamental concepts
and trying to make predictions given the
theoretical work and don't tend to jump
you know at
three sigma-ish results i like to wait
it out and
you know i think it's very interesting
to watch you guys work this out and i
think it's very interesting to see that
the cmb measurements all of them whether
it's plonk or wmap uh you know and
upcoming they agree
so so that's probably you know i don't
know where it comes from whether it's a
late universe whether you know i do
follow the talks i i do follow uh uh you
know the discussion between adam reese
and wendy friedman and others and the
cmb community but i would not um
be willing to write down a theory or
even just say what it is but i must also
say that i believe that the only dark
energy is not the most attractive
explanation that i could imagine if it's
really physics
well in a part two in the future we'll
have to get into that as well as some
similarities perhaps that you pointed
out to me and to others and that and the
potential for the the hicks field to
play uh multiple roles in the bouncing
or cyclic models um but i want to yeah
just touch on what you just said because
i think that's that's really important
we're talking about educating people
and earlier we talked about you know do
we teach about the you know the uh the
the spatial curvature could be negative
one you know it's like no we shouldn't
do that i mean it's it's like teaching
you know that there's no evolution or
something but what bothers me i guess is
that we
i almost see a parallel like people
don't want to teach
uh about
we don't want to teach bouncing models
or alternatives in our standard
cosmology classes and it's kind of like
you know cosmologists working in the
field feel like they're teaching
intelligent designers like it just feels
so uh so uncomfortable teaching about i
think it's stupid i think we should it's
a you know it's a brilliant idea it's an
interesting idea uh people have worked
on this for decades and and people have
an opinion about it that's ill-form
maybe from decades earlier but but
thanks to you and and the reason i bring
this up with respect to you and your
unwillingness to ambulance chase which i
think is a great metaphor um is is uh is
a testament to your taste and i think
that you in particular and this new
generation of young
theorists if i can call you young
without being patronizing uh are super
creative and that you're not just riding
bandwagons chasing trends i feel like
you are incredibly courageous you
personally anna and i hope that this has
inspired some young people in my
audience to to look deeper into what
you've written and i'll have links to
all your all your uh
your vast biography and these phenomenal
papers and talks that you give it's just
like whenever i get to hear one of your
talks and and i was adamant a couple
years back when i organized the seminar
series at caltech that you be one of the
speakers because
your your way of communication is very
forceful it's very logical it's
methodical and and i think it's
open-minded and i think that's lacking
so much in our modern cosmology parlance
and and i wonder part of it is because
you don't go on social media you're
uh you know you it's frustrating because
i can't like tag you in all these cool
places when you do cool stuff but anyway
you don't have to respond to any of that
anna i do i actually i'm happy to i am
happy too no no that's not a problem go
ahead yeah uh this is this is something
um i i i actually think a lot about it
you know i think what's really important
that's why it's probably a short answer
you know i have been very lucky with my
upbringing with my my family and my
schools you know i don't think that one
should be too afraid of what one teaches
kids and what one teaches younger dogs
one should teach them to make up their
own minds and you know if you embrace
them it's it you know very often
that they want to agree with you but
it's really important that you come from
them especially with ideas that you
might not believe in so that they can
make up their own mind and yeah i am not
in social media because i believe apart
look i appreciate what you are doing and
many are doing and i know that social
media has nice aspects but the problem
is also it is also
um encouraging more and more in my view
and i don't think that you know you are
prone to that more you know an
intellectual conformity
on something that you know people are
afraid of having a different opinion
that's what's being established as a
majority opinion and you know this is
not what i'm saying this is
unfortunately something that i
experience and that you know right now
this is a problem in our country and the
problem worldwide and we have to address
how to how to make it a a positive
experience without you know eliminating
viewpoint diversity because we know if
we eliminate that and trade it for fear
and and for conformity out of fear then
we actually stop innovation and my
approach right now
is not to participate in social media i
am happy to go on podcast i'm happy to
uh um give talks that's my job but i
cannot take i think right now the likes
and the dislikes and the comments and
the retweets so this is a very question
you know if galileo had been around and
twitter had been around rather when
galileo was was around back then or
einstein you know they would have had
these blunders and uh and people would
have teased them or my favorite is
maxwell you know james clark's max will
have the maxwell equations and maxwell
boltzmann he had these wonderful ideas
they're all true they're all correct but
if you ask what was the microphysics
behind maxwell's equations they were
vortices and gears and whirlpools and
luminescence ether and he would have
been roasted and maybe you know
cosmologists would have then had to wait
decades you know to think about the
implications for relativity and and the
yang mills equations and all sorts of
things so good good for maxwell lucky
for him that that twitter didn't exist
back then but anna now i want to turn to
the final thrilling three questions that
i ask all my honored guests who come on
the show so
i wish to ask you final three questions
in the in the remaining couple minutes
that we have are you willing to go into
the impossible with me now anna let's
go okay great so the first one of the
thrilling three questions has to do with
what you put in your ethical will when
you reach the age of 120
material will uh but what sorts of
wisdom you touched on some of this a
minute ago but what kind of uh you know
wisdom would you would you most want to
communicate not knowledge of which you
have replete uh you know stored
storehouses but what wisdom would you
want to bequeath
i believe you know i i did mention it
because this is something you know i
find important i think two aspects
perhaps i think it's really important
that one should always have the courage
to make up one's own mind
and then more importantly
one has the courage to stand up to one's
convictions i think it's really
important especially when it gets one
into trouble um not to bend no no no i i
really i really think it's important you
know not not it's really something that
i keep as my life philosophy
make up your own mind about what's right
and do what's right
very nice very good to hear that uh the
next question involves going even
farther into the future
involves these unseen monoliths that are
present in this movie 2001 a space
odyssey came out long before you were
born
uh but it's really kind of a version of
richard feynman's cataclysm question you
know when
some cataclysm erases all human
knowledge what would you put in a time
capsule that really encapsulates what
humans are capable of kind of brag on
behalf of humanity what would you put in
a billion year lasting
you know that will be boring but i i i
it leads us back to your very first
question why i mean cosmology i really
would put in but that should please you
uh the map the temperature and isotropy
map of the cmb with with the equations
that describe it you know it's it's
really because in order to first of all
we share this with everyone in the
universe right this is just our universe
and in that map it's all of our physics
that we figure and also what we haven't
figured
einstein relativity the black body
radiation that photons that light is
particle and wave that electrons the
atomic theory uh you know you know
quantum field theory to understand the
the two and three-point functions or the
statistic you know and what we don't
know where is this coming from what
generated it was there are beginning
where are we going you know dark matter
as the you know what matter made up what
we need the
you know so i i really would you know
this is just it is a little bit like
talking to the bag but
yeah now i i in fact that was my answer
to that same question oh really i didn't
know i put in i i put in the power
spectrum because you know you can get to
get the power spectrum out is a little
bit easier to understand but like you
said it's visible throughout the whole
universe so i actually your answer
contains slightly more information than
mine but i think feynman would be proud
of you uh for answering that way i hope
you would because your answer
obliterates his his was just that the
universe has atoms in it you've got now
atoms radiation photo
i got everything but fireman didn't have
access to the maps right who knows
what's right he's one of my great heroes
so i would hope that if i had ever met
absolutely
last question goes back in time
and it's sort of advice to your former
self and it's the uh statement famous
statement from arthur c clarke the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible so it's the
origin of this podcast name someone
asked you and if you could go back to
your 20 year old self what would you
tell her what would you give her to give
her advice for the courage to go into
the impossible as you have already done
oh wow
um i'm not yet that old right so this is
this is only a little bit more than 10
years back but
um i i guess um
you know i would probably say that you
know it's always worth taking um the
difficult path
if if if if that's uh what my
convictions lead me
and that one manages more than one
beliefs one does so whatever comes at
one actually when one
does the thing that one believes is the
right thing to do one actually gets
through a lot more than
one would have thought one can do and
i'm not yet what enough to say if it was
worth it or not but i know that i think
i would tell my 20 year old said that
i'm actually stronger and i would
believe i am if i follow what i believe
is the right thing to do
uh but yet with bit bit with the um you
know um
footnote i'm not yet that old
so it's not really a vistamai it's more
like um um looking back
15 years in time you know i would say
that that's what i would tell my 20 year
old self
well anna aegis uh dr ann aegis it's
been a pleasure to talk to you i hope we
can get together in person for one of
our long
lingering conversations with you i
always leave it inspired and educated
and i want to thank you for being a
teacher
to to many around the world and an
inspiration of what courage and what
integrity looks like as a scientist anna
thank you so much thanks i appreciate it
thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you